welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how the
big--it's crossover event of all time
might have been a crossover of plot
holes with over sentimental fanservice
[ __ ] but hey I've interesting game
wasn't that bad right no it was great
it feels gonna prove it I'm Erik Bosse
here with Villa Molina hey you know man
hmm things aren't great right now but so
maybe this actually is the right place
for me to come at this question with
what it's like why you got is gotta hate
what you gotta hate the few things that
we like the few things that we should be
able to agree on yes no I'm not allowing
it alright not allowing it well I will
be the judge this week mr. Molina
because my question for you is that if
interest in game actually suck as much
as I want to flippantly just say no
let's move on I do think it's important
that you guys know that we get accused
all the time of being the fanservice
channel the channel that is a simp to
the Mickey a pair of nerds that are you
know milking the teat of the Feige beast
and loving it just like Luke Skywalker
slurping up that Feige milk wiping her
mouth and join every gulp
my point is that we get accused all the
time of refusing to acknowledge one
something at Disney made or Marvel
specifically is not any good and so I'm
gonna lean into it mother for surprise
[ __ ]
let's go item by item we're reaching the
end here for infinity saga re-watch
there's hate for this movie and no you
know what I'm going to full-on fanboy
out ladies and gentlemen of the jury if
you'll allow me today on behalf of my
client Mickey and Feige and what the
hell let's throw in a call yes I'm gonna
address some charges that are being
called plot holes character issues from
all these amazing screenwriters can't
wait to read your scripts saying that
the characters were flawed and people
who said you know what that's the kind
of like cap to the 22 film saga it was a
little bit of a letdown no I will not
allow that okay prosecution is welcome
to share any evidence they have I know
that a lot of it's coming from one so
called cinemasins oh yeah
Eric I don't know how you feel about
cinemasins very funny fun to watch but I
can't get through one of those videos
with at least a couple times saying like
come on
oh really just a couple of times at
least because I assess very heavily
there everything wrong with the vendor's
end game and of course there were some
salient points like the logo showed too
long or the Avengers bathrooms are too
fancy you know maybe my favorite you
know a really really important point to
make is that pepper uses far too many
lamps
why does pepper need five lamps and one
lit candle to read a book about
composting well what's the criticism
there that it's a energy inefficient
to make up of a carbon footprint it's
all probably powered by an arc reactor
like it's burning injury they live in a
farm you know their reefer ttle eyes in
everything and growing all around food
so I will let cinemasins and a few other
sorts of service and prosecution I only
be addressing what I consider to even be
close to legitimate problems this is
substantial charges that they've made
I'm gonna only focus on things that
happen on screen in the film during the
movie because they're still other movies
are gonna be getting made we don't know
what happens off screen yet so by the
end of this video or at least a segment
I expect for you haters out there to
either exonerate this film fully and
accept that it is the greatest superhero
film of all time I'm really happy for
you I'm let you finish one of the best
videos of all time
not counting Dark Knight and maybe even
give it some sort of medal of some kind
or or a sparkle Bach photo books got
your name on it buddy
or you give your welcome hit and
subscribe no it don't talk of that don't
tell them that's an option okay let's
hear it Erik what is what is the case
against my client okay the first charge
that I have for you how did Captain
Marvel not know about Thanos and his
stolen mission earlier Captain Marvel
policeman of the the universe is
theoretically gonna know about all major
threats here's the thing
Captain Marvel as she made very clear
there are a lot of other planets in the
universe and unfortunately they didn't
have you guys is dealing with an
insanely huge threat very far away and
Erik do you know how big the universes
[Music]
men in black marble know that's out
that's an internal galaxy universes
where those aliens live how can they fit
it all on that one disk that's spinning
in space that 2d hurricane that is the
universe what we want is to respect the
fact it is insanely huge and here's the
two reasons why that's awesome one that
means that she's gonna get a sequel film
that is she's dealing with something so
major that she was distracted and two it
shows us how the Marvel Cinematic
Universe isn't anywhere close to being
done yet
where Thanos isn't exactly registering
on her radar because she's aware of how
big the other threats are in the
entire universe but let's keep it really
narrow for a second all we need to do is
establish a little bit of doubt here of
why she wouldn't care in a moment he
didn't have the stones yet and from the
moment that he has all the stones yes he
is now a universe level threat and she
comes running and smashing when she
needs to at that point before then he's
kind of a local hometown thug like you
were that's right and you know I'm still
I'm still Eric from the block I'm still
Eric from the block okay I got the ass
that won't quit either I couldn't pull
dance I can pull that off as soon as we
get back in the studio I'm forcing us to
a pole dancing episode
you don't gotta force it I I think you
make a very good point Phillip and
Captain Marvel there's lots of warlords
and the Thanos to stone quest happen
overnight it's hard to keep up with that
I get it another charge though when
Scott Lang was going through the streets
of San Francisco after being awoken by a
rat
why would trash still be piled on the
streets five years later Eric really
this is your charge I said the streets
of San Francisco not the surfaces of my
bedroom oh this wasn't a personal
reactivation but I love when you out
yourself it's like that episode that we
had to bleep your bathroom ASAPS
that's right buddy you show that
Turner's boss here's the thing it's five
years later and certain streets in San
Francisco are covered in trash we did
not see you know a sweeping survey of
all the streets of San Francisco
[Music]
so people wondering why would there be
so much trash five years later you got
to remember that we're kind of like what
we're dealing with now people pay
different attentions honestly to the
neighborhood's that yell the loudest
this is a serious per second here but
there's a reason why protests tend to be
focused in the neighborhoods where the
decision makers live or where the news
cameras want to show up because that's
where you get the attention but that's
also the first place to institute new
changes so if something like the snap
happened there are gonna be all kinds of
issues with foreclosures unclear
ownership of certain homes and they
decimated will not decimate it half a
maded workforce of sanitation workers so
all of those things combined so that
absolutely there is going to be a trash
issue of citywide countrywide worldwide
but they're probably getting there and
it's much better in certain places but
with that reduced work force and then a
bad census of who even lives on what
streets which streets are nearly empty
now which streets are maybe dangerous
now to enter and there probably is a
much reduced schedule of picking up that
trash especially in certain
neighborhoods Ranas say they just don't
care about those people that much and
that might be the kind of neighborhood
that Scott Lang's family lives in what
the hell happened here very good point
anyone who lives in New York City at
least knows that it doesn't take that
long for the trash to build up even when
society is supposed to function
incorrectly and let's talk about Pym
particles so if you were watching last
week's episode you know the quantum
realm has some explaining to do first of
all Avengers make their first trip just
going to Hank Pym snakes in 70s lab and
steal plenty of Pym particles to give
them lots of room for error and then
they wouldn't have such a limited supply
why didn't they do that Phillip why
didn't they do it well one screenwriting
wise we want a limited resource to be
part of this whole thing right how many
bullets you got left it's like how many
Pym particles you got left and then you
know if it was like oh good thing I own
an ammo store it's not as tense a film
if they just have endless Pym particles
but you want an in-universe explanation
do you not yes I always do and there
always must be one a couple reasons one
they are worried about making
unnecessary trips in general anyway so
adding another trip that's just one to
go get all that all the Pym particles
not ideal but more important let's say
they go back to Penn's lab early on in
his research and wipe out his storage of
Pym particles or maybe even they just
take half of what he's got at Pym
particles but he's barely got a stable
enough situation to maintain the ones he
does have what's gonna be a bigger issue
to the eventual ramifications of their
adjustments to the timeline them taking
just enough just as many as they need to
accomplish their task or let's take this
thing that we're relying on to save the
whole world and anything that ant-man in
the future has done anything that the
previous ant-man had done in the past
let's wipe that out nearly let's make it
much more likely that he's gonna have
issues with the fact that he suddenly
his first major batch of Pym particles
is mostly gone it is gonna be too
destructive to the past it's a major
it's like going back and taking the kite
out of Einstein's hand when he invents
gravity that is not correct
like it's it's too big a deal I can see
that point I think the writers and the
directors of the movie aren't really
clear on whether or not time travel
works like they say it's not Back to the
Future if you make a change in the past
it doesn't like have a ripple effect to
the president it creates a new timeline
but the writers seem to like double back
on that and all their interpretations
since then yeah so there has been a lot
of debate about where they they settled
on how time travel affects things I will
say that I'm gonna address this exact
issue in in a future part of this case
so stay tuned but let's just say that it
is very important that they don't ruin
younger Hank Pym Michael Douglas pre
kind of Lingus cancer not everyone knows
that reference as quickly as we did you
confuse so many people just this moment
we made it in a previous episode a big
question it's a nickname on the back of
his jersey folks Phil can I have a bit
of a shorthand that you'll you'll pick
up on and you'll just get up
okay well sting with Pym particles here
to me this is the biggest plot hole in
the movie just my personal gripe how did
that oh s--- get more Pym particles -
like we know he had one but he brought
up his whole fleet to the president how
did that happen this this is your your
biggest plot hole this is your biggest
Asian it's like the most annoyingly
unexplained one there's there's other
bigger consequences ones this is just
one where it's like you didn't even
bother to come up with an explanation
for this there is an explanation right
okay
yes nebula was able to bring her sweet
sweet purple daddy a little Pym particle
but remember that with Thanos is ebony
ma who is a genius level scientist this
guy with Thanos these people have been
traveling through space for who knows
how long for longer than anyone really
to compare our stupid little Michael
Douglas pre-cancer ability of science to
what they can do especially once they
have an item to reverse engineer they
were able to very quickly take this kind
of impressive little particle Mick oh
yeah I find how that works
mmm and just make as many as they need
they're just way more advanced
technologically than we are okay I mean
I get it reverse engineer it's just too
easy of an answered for something that
happened off screen but you know what we
didn't think about it in the moment I'll
say that when I watched the movie I
didn't really think about it I'll say
there was a TV show once that I really
liked that I forgot what it's called
right now like I got canceled real quick
he like kind of connects he explores two
timelines at the same time and one time
he accidentally leaves his iPhone back
in the 60s and when he comes back to
present-day everything's different it's
like a hundred years in the future now
because like just these one little
glimpses that things to reverse-engineer
they can inspire a whole world of
eternal Steve Jobs equivalents up
anymore let's move on at the moment of
the snap how
was it light daylight in Wakanda and New
York with Maria Hill and Nick Fury but
also in San Francisco and the Hawkeye
farm in Iowa all at the same time how is
it all daylight I bet you think you're
so clever pointing this out right oh
it's daylight in different places around
the world how is that possible at the
exact same time unless the earth is flat
is that what you're getting that that's
it the Sun was just shining on all of it
God aimed it Eric it's easy
it's called 5:00 p.m. in East Africa at
5:00 p.m. in East Africa where what
Conda is it would be light out correct
sure all right say no just say yes what
it's 5:00 p.m.
just say yes I'm going in San Francisco
so all the way across United States it
is 7:00 a.m. at that time light is out
and then in New York City it would be
10:00 a.m. so all of the United States
and a significant amount of Africa
perfectly within daylight hours now the
only thing I will say is that you might
think hey that means that Hawkeye and
his family are having a hot dog brunch
at 9 a.m. in Iowa yeah who eats hot dogs
with no mustard is that earlier that eh
that's the issue that that early well
you know what no you know what farmers
do farmers wake up at 5:00 a.m. to go
yell at a horse so four hours later that
is lunch time for them they're just
they're just getting started they're
gonna get ready for bed soon 2 p.m. I
don't know Philip I think 7 a.m. in San
Francisco would not be that bright out
they have this big fog layer called Carl
it dampens the light so it's pretty dark
that early in the day it just it looked
like more of an 11:00 a.m. shoot time
than a 7 a.m. shoot time just say
all right I want to move on to some
issues that we may call subjective
issues that deal with characters and
plots but are worth discussing so our
discuss seniors right that's okay
let's discuss the combination Bruce
Banner and Hulk it left us with a
character who is neither Bruce nor the
Hulk but it was kind of a fusion of the
of the two but like it was still
basically banners mind what happened to
the Hulk identity we got to know with
the record their identity fully exists
anymore and that's why they've had to do
they've been from the beginning here's a
here's the thing that's unfair to really
put too much on the Hulk from the
beginning of this new version of the MCU
they haven't been able to give Hulk his
do they have to tell his story
tangentially inside of the story of the
other characters and in Avenger stories
and in Thor stories it's unfair because
of the stupid Universal rules and
whatnot but that means they kind of had
to stick with it so unfortunately the
culmination of this characters arc where
it's essentially the Jekyll and Hyde
story right these these two completely
disparate beings the idea that at some
point they can exist harmoniously in the
what is it the by cameras mind something
that exists in two completely different
states at the same time that is kind of
a beautiful resolution for a character
that we saw as either brilliant or a
behemoth or a beast or something to be
able to put them in this central place
is a very interesting place to take it
to and also it would make sense that
that character is not quite all of
either if those are two extremes then he
kind of can't be fully so maybe he is
actually a little weaker than if he was
pure Hulk and went fully that way right
so you know the fact that he slept with
his arm in a sling it might might make
me sense but also like I said a few
weeks back he probably not he has smart
ether has happy work just pure Bruce
Banner but it's okay because at least
he's living in harmony and this poor guy
has been tortured with his broken mind
otherwise so it's a nice evolution of
the character and a nice completion of
the first part at least of the Hulk arc
hopefully fingers crossed we actually
get to explore the character
the real way with maybe his own films or
something moving forward but it's the
best they could do
also they had to cut a story for time
for sure fair enough fair enough
and you know what like all the things
we're talking about if it doesn't bother
you while you're watching the movie it
really counts as a plot hole and I would
agree with you on this that seeing Hulk
in this new forum is far more satisfying
than like the complications that may
arise later on when you're thinking
about it but let's talk about another
example of this and I don't necessarily
agree with this argument but I am
bringing it up because other people have
brought it to our attention their
argument the character of fat Thor this
this new version of him you can just
call him Thor Erik but then people might
get confused what movie were talking
about like they forgot what the title
the video it's like back when sitcom
title used to be insensitive it's simple
it's fast or you can't some people will
say it's it's not so much just wait but
it's his emotional state so some people
might say that he makes light of mental
health issues by bringing it up this
this new stage of depression he's then
some people think depression is is a
joke
that you can just quickly move on from
by losing weight he and he doesn't lose
weight which i think is actually a
powerful choice they made that he
doesn't just cure himself it's you know
what honestly I know that their plan
initially was that he'd be skinny again
at the end or jacked at the end and I
think that that would have made this
argument a lot more valid if it was to
say sad people are fat and healthy you
know Jack people are happy and and you
know actual heroes neither of those
things is true it's it's too extreme
this is actually a much more authentic
depiction of what it's like to go
through depression first of all kudos to
them before for putting the mental
health of one of the most powerful
beings in the universe in a fragile
state to show like yeah even this
freaking guy goes through it so it's
okay that we go through it especially
during these times of epic level of
disorder and change and feeling like you
know you aren't worthy is something that
they always put in the comics as kind of
a thing that a king wonders about but
honestly a day to day the average person
they kind of wonder sometimes like man I
don't feel worthy of my own life and
what is that what does that version of
depression look like it does look a lot
more like what we see there where you
don't really want to go outside you just
want to hang
a couple of friends you're comfortable
with you kind of become more of an
introvert
what does tend to happen when you stay
inside and you're not active and you
don't really honestly care about your
appearance your hair grows out gained
weight you maybe all you do is play
video games or something it's not an
inauthentic representation the fact that
they brought it in at all is to be
applauded and then honestly had they
done it in a really dark intense way
people would have seen that as either
pandering or that is making a mockery of
what people's mental health state is
like where you know it only exists in
that way some of the saddest moments in
my life are probably when I've been some
of the funniest performances that I've
had at that time - I know you've had
that - yeah I definitely felt that way I
this is the one argument that I will
bring up that I don't necessarily agree
with I think it was a great character
art I completely connected with him and
I don't think it was laughing oh wait I
thought it was very appropriately dealt
with so he's one way over could you
imagine if it also wasn't like funny at
all to see how Thor scenes after Thor
Ragnarok yeah like he suddenly was
almost super dragon serious again oh
it'd be insane but this is one thing
that I think is a bit inexcusable
Natasha's death
it was glossed over she did not get a
funeral which Tony Stark did get a big
funeral well what's the deal first off
just that last point Tony Stark getting
a funeral is because Tony Stark is not
just the lead of Avengers end game Tony
Stark is the lead character of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe up to this
point completely today Tony yes entirely
his arc his thing I mean they the fact
that they flew in that kid
Harley whatever just like the fact that
they kept that child actor alive just to
play this role you know like that's how
much they wanted to show that it was a
big deal that this is Tony's end but
also keep in mind they know that there
they've got a black widow movie on the
slate they can we have no idea what's
gonna happen in that hopefully they
release it at some point soon but not
only is she gonna have more story to be
told but it might not even be the end of
her story yet I think it's important -
this is one where it's like you know
what they know that this character is
worth more that's why they're giving her
a whole film we got to hold off on
you know if that's the only film she
ever gets and it has an unsatisfying
ending there and she just died sadly a
nun game yeah maybe becomes a legitimate
complaint but right now it's too early
to tell
good point we'll suspend our judgment
until black widow comes out in 2024
thank you strike that one from the
charges stricken now this is a point
that it could mean a lot of different
things but some people have argued that
the movie has too much mixing of tones
it won't really clear how to emotionally
react to any given moment if it was
meant to be too dramatic it's a moment
too comedic there's just too much
emotion I guess is that is that what
we're complaining about my emotions
right yes well that's a good point and
you have to address it that's bull I
think that there's a reason why the rise
of drama D has been so strong
people want complex storytelling the age
of of justice CBS sitcom and the you
know dark Special Victims Unit kind of
procedural or something and those two
worlds being so disparate is not
interesting to us anymore it's kind of
the same thing we're saying about the
Hulk earlier right it's actually how the
way that these things can coexist that
is more interesting but also more
authentic and true to life but I'll also
remind you we've had both of those
things and people love those either one
of the biggest issues that people don't
like about Avengers the Joss Whedon
first Avengers film is they're like oh
it has almost too light of an energy for
how epic it should be it suppose to be
this this amazingly epic film but it's
very colorful it's light it comes from a
guy who's mostly known for TV so a lot
of people are like that that movie just
like doesn't like hit with a wall up
that you that you want it to and I'd say
infinity war an end game both did hit
with that and then you know what happens
when you get too dark Martha there's a
Superman and everybody was like like
holy crap I mean Batman is a dark
character but Superman also 64 in like
that whole world that talked about a
place that seems like San Francisco with
no sunlight or something that world is
drained of anything that resembles our
our lives either so you can't have it
both ways you can't be mad at that and
can't be mad at that this was a more
authentic representation of the world as
it is and also you know when you're
dealing with like super crazy dark sad
stuff like a lot of us kind of can
really
right now it's also weirdly can still be
a funny fun interesting time we've had a
lot of fun doing these episodes a big
question right smack in the middle of
all this miserable [ __ ] that's right
okay I want to move on to some of the
issues with in-game as a culmination to
the whole infinity saga series okay the
big one being the introduction
time-travel a lot of people argue it
removes the stakes for all future MC
movies because anytime something goes
wrong they now have a way they can just
fix it with time-travel so this is what
I was alluding to earlier that you could
think that maybe the Avengers could have
solved things differently with time
travel before so I would say that part
of the blame here comes with the fact
that the Russo brothers and also the
writers and also foggy they've all
depicted time travel a little bit
differently whatever they make
statements about it but where it seems
like we might be landing right now at
the most recent statements I've read is
actually a lot more in line with what
Reed Richards defines time travel to be
like in Marvel Comics and that's the
concept that when you go back in time
and you do anything at all even really
the act of going back in time it's not a
closed loop right you can't affect that
time that you just came from but you are
actually visiting another dimension
where these different events happen
there's two important takeaways from
that one that means that no they did not
erase anything that's ever happened in a
Marvel movie before it is not different
that all really did happen and all is
canon still so even all the way through
Loki's deaths right Loki did die that is
canon that character is had his neck
snapped the fact that we're seeing new
adventures now is more akin to something
like the ultimate storyline branching
off from the main Marvel comics where
now we see characters we've seen before
they'd even live some stories that maybe
we've seen before but it is not
replacing what came before so you can't
say it removes the stakes of things that
came before when technically the fact
that we previously had other spider-man
movies go web go hey wait you can recast
him as Tom Holland but now I'm not
worried about Tobey Maguire
[Applause]
technically they're starting a whole new
thing by doing time travel at all yeah
you can't judge an earlier movie based
off of things that happen later in a
series but even even then the way that
they're designing it is that they're
saying we cannot change the things that
have already happened in this series we
can only make new things so all your old
stuff is still precious and perfect
second thing that I disagree with about
this idea of the time traveller mistakes
is that they are playing this idea of
trope deconstruction that we've talked
about before where Lord and Miller are
really good at this where they take
ideas that we've seen before and they
really get into them of what the
ramifications are so something like the
blip and mr. Harrington's wife
pretending to disappear too that's the
kind of ingenuity that they're applying
to these storylines and things we've
maybe seen this idea of people going
missing we've seen a couple shows like
that but people pretending to have done
it now apply those brains toward
something like time travel this is my
hypothesis but a hundred percent think
that's gonna happen we're gonna see
ramifications of time travel that are
much bigger than we've ever seen
anything else we're gonna see new dramas
new stakes that are because of messing
the time we've talked about the time
variant authority potentially getting
getting involved here there if you know
Marvel Comics you know that time travel
is not something that is dealt with
lightly so actually they might have just
made things a lot worse for themselves
so it's actually very exciting to see
not only how they're gonna reinvent time
travel style stories but also how
they're gonna take existing time to have
a related stories that really mess
things up and bring them into the movies
fair enough fair enough and another
criticism some people feel about it that
it didn't correctly end the character
arc of Black Widow Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers having to end the character arc
of three different characters in one two
and a half hour movie already very
difficult to do especially be characters
that we care a lot about but we can
acknowledge what is important for these
arcs and ask did endgame do that so iron
man's kind of be the obvious one right
Tony was very selfish that's how we met
him he was a person he found eventually
that you know it's not just about him
and he found a family and the Avengers
but also a little family with pepper and
his daughter and he was at a
point where he wanted that more than he
wanted to be Iron Man more than he
wanted to be a hero
so he had all that growth that we
realize an end game and then is finally
tested in the in the most difficult way
of finally becoming the man that is not
wanting to be alone and wanting me a
unit here with the family and then
identifying the last drip of selfishness
of him wanting to have that for himself
is technically still him being selfish
and so he pulls that away and lets
himself die in order to save everyone
else that character definitely completes
his arc in in and then some then moving
on I'll say Captain America is probably
the next obvious one since we you know
really saw that he becomes an old man at
the end so it really feels like they've
ended it but Steve almost started as the
opposite of Tony and he's all about
service and self-sacrifice and he hates
the fact that Tony is the other way and
the and the fact that we end him in a
moment where he doesn't want to talk
about the life he's lived with Peggy in
the in that moment he has some details
about it and that he decides you know
what it's more important for me to allow
myself happiness than to go back and
continue whatever other Captain America
movies I have to make instead Chris
Evans is like I just want to get there
yeah
the actor said that but that's a Troy a
personal choice and so realizing that
his own life is valid and worthy to just
be happy and to is a nice Commission of
that character and then finally Black
Widow I mean it's it's again I think
there's a black widow movie coming we
might see a lot more meat put on that
stories bones but I think in just
capping off with her sacrificial act it
does address the one thing that we knew
was the gaping hole in black widows life
and that's the fact that she's done so
much bad she has a lot of red on her
ledger is there any way to make up for
that and it is to give her life to bring
back as much life as she can of course
she can't undo the past but it's the
only way to add kind of black to her
ledger try to balance her books
it seems decent at least okay and one
final criticism some people feel the
movie was too
servus see doesn't that mean like you
get somebody off what kind of fan
doesn't want to be serviced I rest my
case
all right no more needs to be said Wow
Philip you want to wrap this up in
closing statement oh [ __ ] ah yeah I'll
say I love how many people were
listening to this whole thing to this
point and they're like you know I kind
of hated endgame but now why are you
subscribe for so long
reasons for doing something like that
would be could be manic I'll say I think
I've addressed a lot of alleged problems
with the movie but I want to also remind
you the scrutiny that this movie is even
trying to live up to Citizen Kane
considered the best film of all time
was not dealing with even a couple
decades worth of film to come before it
this movie has 80 years of movies before
and comics that have explored every way
that something can be done and yet we
can all even agree that there's things
that are just done for the first time at
this level on this movie that it should
not have even been breaking new ground
but it is the most ambitious engaging
team battle we've ever seen in a movie
of course you know are there more tense
team battles that have existed sure but
the scale and epicness of this that you
also witness that scale and care so much
about the number of characters it's kind
of like the opening scene to Saving
Private Ryan is epic and level and
length and I would say if they're
comparable now imagine if 20 or 30 of
the characters that are out there
storming the beaches of Normandy you're
like no don't get hurt I'm worried about
each and every one of you and I know
your name and I know your backstory and
I care about each of you and I hope your
arcs are being paid off so even with
half of the key characters snapped away
the ones that are there we still cares
that much about and they still have
these satisfying emotional arcs and
their motivations the fact that this
movie is even coherent and
understandable for everything you need
to have in it that's remarkable much
less the fact that it's good enough that
people cheer out loud at moments
line at the end credits and two and a
half hours they wrapped up put 2223
movies culminating in the most
impressive ambitious and lucrative movie
in the history of film basically they
stuck the landing
so is it perfect no especially some of
the science but if we wanted perfect
science then we would watch Bill Nye in
his perfect body we wanted a moving
cinematic experience on an epic scale
and it delivered all right was it my
turn now to weigh in as a judge are you
the judge the whole time I have been the
same person I'm just the judge I think
it's might I have to give you a verdict
to put up such a well researched and
argued argument they were going to get
that uh the goat guy from mr. Sunday
movies not the acronym goat I think he's
just a goat yeah he's the goat of what
he does it's great no that's fine if
you're the judge I would have been a lot
nicer to you this whole team yeah yeah
maybe you should consider that just
don't do that what am i doing this is
stupid
no you know you commit to your bit you
know when it got a suit jacket from the
big and tall store for this bit during
quarantine common law traditions are
stupid
we stopped wearing powdered wigs in
America we should stop putting them in
these fancy bathrobes - I like how many
people in the in the viewing audience
and most the listeners have no idea what
just happened even the viewers are like
I think Eric tried to make two puppets
be a two-headed Judge it was a robe all
right Philip I was going to weigh a
different direction but now no I think
if the question on the table is did
endgame suck of course not of course you
made a very good argument for why this
movie deserves to be considered cinema
and deserves to rank among some of the
best films experiences of all time and
definitely deserves to be those
profitable film of all time it
definitely earned all of that I do think
it is a very good movie and experience
I'll never forget
I do think the fact that this made so
much money allows it a
bit more of a target on its back for
people to criticize and the same way
that people criticize avatar it's
already made all of its money it's
already paid for so many grandkids
colleges this point so do we need do we
need to say it's also artistically
perfect no it's not and I do think there
are more questions than answers when it
comes to not just a science but just the
movie's own internal logic it's not
things that we could just forgive to the
screenwriters for saying like well you
did everything else right
it would it robbed the movie of some
very interesting payoff with Steve
Rogers return journey there's some
really interesting storytelling that
they just sidestepped because they just
wanted this site reveal of old Steve
Rogers which I agree when I watched it I
thought was very moving but I will say
that refrigerator logic kicked in about
halfway to the walk to the refrigerator
of like what the hell did we just see
like why is he old now like it confused
me too quick after the ah moment had
they just ended with like him being back
in the 40s dance with Peggy Carter would
have been perfect they didn't need to
have old man Steve it could have just
showed him in the past and he wouldn't
have all these haters I think you would
have fewer haters but at the end of the
day Philip I think your argument is
valid is that what the case was a murder
trial oh did they kill cinema by making
this movie I will do what the Supreme
Court does all the time to say starry
decisis we're gonna let a lower court
ruling stand because we're all political
acts now that we've chosen for political
reasons to applying real judicial
principle these the two puppets the
puppets ran away and now they're
puppeting me the puppets was our
political system the entire time isn't
that the bit the entire time the entire
time the entire entire time
well we're getting an entire time now
one of the biggest grievances fans have
with their lives it's the fact that many
of them are losing their hair they find
that up bummer like that segue seamless
they say that two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 if you
can believe it yeah professor Eck's
probably still wishes he look like
McEvoy if he had a say in it he would
probably want to use keeps thank you to
keep sponsoring this episode with keeps
it's easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and hope
you keep there that you already have
yeah they offer the generic versions of
the two fda-approved hair loss products
others same ones I've use which are the
only things that really work they're
half the cost of the what they cost of
the pharmacy yeah and you know what you
don't even have to go to your doctor's
office if you use it you can just do it
all from home where you probably you
know stuck right now anyway you just
meet with a doctor online and they ship
that treatment right to your home they
also have more five-star reviews than
any of their competitors I think it's
like a hundred thousand men use them for
their hair loss prevention medication
yeah so if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss just go to keeps
calm slash big question to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
ke e PS comm slash big question - - and
you think you can pull this do you
remember that from ten hours ago when we
started this I think I can I think I can
I hope that's what you're doing on the
pole it's like stop shouting your mantra
or say it's sexier you know what I think
I can do I think I can tell you that
we've got some bite size questions for
you are you ready yeah let's do it all
right number one jackal is eighteen this
one's from discord
if Asgardians lived for 5000 years how
much time has passed for Thor during his
time in the MCU oh because we have
flashes of him and other times - right
that's right yeah and they just we just
know as Guardians have this longer
lifespan well okay so in Avengers
infinity war which you know we just
rewatched Thor told rocket you know I'm
1500 years old which you know if you
think about he was probably rounding up
because according to most sources and
pretty sure of Thor was like born
sometime in the nine hundreds before
nine
sixty-five but sometime in that century
but that would mean he was closer to
1100 but let's take him at his word 1500
years old so assuming that has Guardian
life span of 5000 years that would mean
he is 30% of the way through his life so
if we map that over a human life span
which place it around 80 years or so he
would be the equivalent 30% into that of
24 years old so the Thor we're looking
at is like a 24 year old Asgardian so
things like it yeah he's got that kind
of sensibility right in the years that
we've seen at the MCU Thor's first movie
was in 2011 and game was 2023 that's 12
years so in an adze Guardian numbers
that would equate to about 70 days of
his life
right if he was going through normal so
it's like imagine the whole MCU is
passed by for Thor for what would be
about two months from our perspective
but the reason I say from our
perspective is time is relative it's an
abstract invention that humans used to
keep track of everything when we were
younger
two months feels like a really long time
when we're older time seems to be moving
faster two months is like yeah I can do
two months but to a guy in his early 20s
like 70 days can be a very influential
period in one's life like that's that's
an unforgettable summer that's one crazy
semester in college that's a real
turbulent relationship you know
so to Thor he's like yeah he's a college
age bro
who for the past two months has
experienced more ups and downs than at
any point earlier in his life and that's
a completely reasonable thing Erik dad
to say very well thought out interesting
answer I'm sorry I think I misread the
question though it's how much screen
time has passed for Thor in minutes in
the in Marvel movies oh I'll be right
back I could say that he had 14 and a
half minutes and infinity work and I
don't know anything other than that do
you know about anything
your mother's name ooh Martha number two
Logan wants to know this is awesome
discord uh-huh thank you for your
service how do parents and genetics work
in the matrix okay so oh this is really
interesting actually so if two people
are your parents in the matrix do you
actually have the DNA of those two
people
your real body that is a very good
question
the machines playing like matchmaker
between like yeah they must because
there are bodies in the matrix look like
our bodies in the real world Keanu
Reeves has the same appearance you know
default but the Negro's back well okay
let's think back Morpheus did say humans
are no longer born human beings so that
would imply that in the farms of the
real world where although the pods are
sex cells are being harvested the sperm
egg from human pods and then they're
taken they're mixed in there just stated
and artificial wombs where the babies
incubated and then they spend their
whole life in that in that pod but yeah
our projections and the matrix do look
like a real cell so presumably the
matrix must be monitoring hmm
which projections in the simulation are
hooking up they're like okay these two
okay let's go back and look at the
archives and they go find those pods in
the real world and then like all right
and then like Doc Brown like with the
and it takes them so that you know it
all corresponds real world versus matrix
and then like when the twos computerized
simulation or not simulations but just
like they they have sex they'll make it
happen in the real world as well so that
their offspring will inherit their
traits and then they create a version of
that for their matrix but I think
something that we have to acknowledge is
that originally the Wachowski z-- did
intend on another element to their world
building that there would be identity
switching with some people between the
simulation in the real world at least in
their original concept so the character
switched that character was named switch
because originally they were going to be
trans there's gonna be one gender in the
real world another gender in the matrix
and that would suggest that our
projections and the matrix don't have to
match our real appearances and that the
machines like if you would think about
it the machines what would be most
efficient for them is to just like
randomize who would mate with whom and
just try to biologically make the most
efficient battery they wouldn't they
wouldn't try to play matchmaker you know
like they would they would just be like
this with us
they do that and they rewrite the story
and that's like why it's like I'm
suddenly drawn to you Eric right right
but that would just imply that like we
have less free will in the matrix which
I know we don't have really any free
will but like it seems like there are
life decisions we can make that have
consequences within our algorithm so it
just depends on where on the spectrum of
free will you think things are falling
there is some free will in the matrix
but I think what we'll see matrix for is
coming out my prediction for that movie
is I think they're going to give us some
clear answers on how reproduction works
just because that question of identity
is so crucial to the Wachowski story
right like and I think they're gonna
want to be able to tell that because
they they were forced to remove that
backstory from switch in the original
matrix and I would not be surprised if
that is addressed in the new Matrix
movie considered like how big that story
is now and in our site in our culture so
I think that will be part of it I think
we're gonna learn that some people the
reason why they look like their parents
in and out of the matrix is because
they're just made this old-fashioned way
of the matrix playing matchmaker turkey
basters yeah there will be some that are
the result of anomalies of just these
randomized mixings
that have different appearances and both
their their gender identity maybe even
their race in and out of the matrix
which will be a very interesting topic
to address Eric we got to move on
because you are getting me hot oh I do
too click when you talk about Doc Brown
it's your kids Marty
we gotta make them it's just became Rick
and Morty yeah all right number three I
this is from two people on the discord
ah speaking of love matched
reven and every rose I want to know an
infinity war how did did they both ask
these questions they both asked it they
both asked it in infinity war how did
Heimdall know exactly where on earth to
send Hulk exactly where Doctor Strange
was basically like through the window oh
yeah how do you have the coordinates
right well there was a scene in Thor
Ragnarok that established that Thor and
Heimdall can like weirdly link
telepathically like there's a moment
where Thor was on Sekar Heimdall was
holding things down on Asgard and
through like his words eyes because he
can peer into the soul of everyone -
their eyes glowed Thor's eyes glowed the
same color and they were just like links
like Thor's
consciousness teleported over to as
garden they can just like live in a
FaceTime chat like that's just a rule
the world that would that was introduced
in that movie first time yes so there
was that moment in Finney Worth Aniston
feeds Hulk and there's a brief look
between Thor and Heimdall where they
make eye contact and the light really
reflects off of inter-cell Bo's eyes to
make them look super orange and I think
that was the moment where Thor
telepathically gave Heimdall directions
saying look it's too late for me but
let's send banner to earth to the
sanctum sanctorum which I just met this
guy dr. Steven strange he can teleport
people around places instantly so we can
link it's probably the safest place to
send him right now to send this message
of warning I think it happened in that
moment telepathically off screen so like
show me the place in your mind where you
wanted to go yes very cool Eric there's
time for one quick quick mailbox
question is that a box there's a bag no
one knows the old hag it's a box don't
call me a hag oh it's on a little strip
this time speaking of a little strip
Eric's pull dance episode coming soon I
can't take this off it's just like a
chest Dickie Eric have you ever bullied
anyone intentionally or by accident oh
I've done bone I raise your hand if you
feel like you've been victimized yeah I
mean hey I was a little sneaker all
through grade school in high school and
everyone who feels like they've been a
victim of bullying it's probably also
dished it back out we're all victimizing
each other all right I definitely
bullied someone didn't realize I did it
at the time I was called out later so in
college Philip and I we mentioned that
we were part of this big improv cult it
was a cult there's a big improv group I
think what people don't understand is
this is not like your college improv
group where there's like 10 or 12 kids
like their acapella group and they just
do their random shows and no one laughs
and it's weird this was a hundred people
and we had this weird deal with the
theatre College where they let us come
in and teach their improv classes each
of which had 40 kids in it and all of
those students according to our
Constitution were members of our club
they were required to go see your shows
yeah so they had to buy a shirt from us
and perform at our shows for their class
credit so at any given time we had like
a hundred people who were part of this
club but it was such a weird group of
people it was wonderful and that like we
would just have these events like we
would get booked to do a show and then
we'd all beaten the Student Union and
just gonna take over a corner of it and
you'd see like 20 or 30 of us all just
show up and just like do bits
it was so goofy you would go into a
classroom somewhere and you just find
people just doing a bit and like it's a
show going on we don't really know
because everyone's constantly on trying
to make each other laugh and there was a
show that we were booked for one time
and our meeting place is going to be in
our Student Union cinema which has like
it has a little stage there and I go up
and I have like my newspaper soon
newspaper and I'm just like sitting
there looking around and I see like our
buddy Rudy waiting for the show to start
and some of them I think they're warming
up they're like down on the stage area
I'm sitting in the back of the cinema
and like they're all goofing around so I
think they're just doing warm-ups and
then so I'm reading the newspaper I'm
chatting with other people as they're
arriving and then someone else comes in
and they're like what is Rudy doing and
when I saw them before they're just like
dancing around like doing stupid voices
up on the stage and they were taking
turns getting up on the stage and I
barely look up for my newspaper I'm like
what's going on and someone in in that
group look over and they go he's doing a
comedy and then I just like kind of
laugh and I go like he's trying to but
like I thought they're all just doing
bits later everyone was really weird
around me and I was like what is going
on and and Rudy was really weird around
me I went home and my friend and
roommate Max is that we were living
together that time he said give us what
why'd you say that to Rudy I'm like what
are you talking about he's like you
heckled him like no I did it he's like
Puss you totally heckled him when he was
trying to do stand-up and then I liked
it Bruce Willis in the sixth sense
replayed the night and like everything
reassembled and I was able to see myself
from a third-person perspective and what
had actually happened was
Rudy had sent all of us a message in
during announcements that said hey I'm
going to get to this venue half hour
earlier to test out some stand-up that I
am working on and everyone had gathered
at the front of the cinema to watch him
test out his stand-up for a show he was
gonna be doing like it was like a
competition show I stroll in there with
my student newspaper don't understand
what's going on because I probably
wasn't paying attention to when Rudy
asked for people to come support him and
give him feedback and I sit down there
and I read my newspaper talking during
his show to other people and then when
someone asks what's Rudy doing they turn
around and we're probably like he's
trying to do comedy or like he's doing a
show right now and I go huh he's trying
and then I realized that I had heckled
him and I looked like a huge [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then I messaged him later
I'm like you're not gonna believe me I
it wasn't what it seems I didn't realize
what you were doing but in order to
explain to him that I wasn't heckling
him I had to reveal that I just
completely ignored earlier when he was
talking to the whole group so either way
I was just a huge douche bag and this
was a nicely there were other times
where I like accidentally said things to
Rudy that I did not mean and so in his
head he's like this guy just has it out
for me this I don't know why this guy's
being such a douche bag but it was an
[ __ ] and I bully don't Eric here's
the saddest part about it the fact that
you were in charge of the team that he
was on because I remember that you were
the director of his team that's right as
his coach yeah means he thought you were
there specifically to support him he
thought it was the moment where his
teacher came to the back of the room
didn't want to make a scene and just
wanted to watch his student be you know
all that he believes it can be and
instead that's the person that turned on
him yeah and you know what heckled not
only that I replayed the night and I
remembered briefly as my eyes moved back
to the newspapers seeing him on the
stage and just as still frame of him
frozen his like whole demeanor just
sunken like imagine imagine if you're
doing a show for your friends and you
invited one of your friends and he
heckled you with the meanest bean way
you're directing some
respect is the equivalent of imagine
your dad finally came to your baseball
game that you loser and your dad's the
coach of the team
take him out okay kid sucks Robbie
you're my son you're getting ice cream I
how about you bullying um I wish I was
rated what's funny is that I I mean I
got like mildly bullied at times and
then I think I got snarky back so that I
ended up bullying my bullies that way
but I'd I never felt like I was really a
bully bully I've always been like to
into having friends as much as I could
and but then I were talking and I zoned
out I remember don't get it but I did
remembered it from the same group of
cult brides there was a person there
that is the only person that is ever on
my enemy list I know you'll keep a very
long enemy list okay it's kind of work
my way down out of it if I can but a lot
of people do kind of norm honestly you
hold a grudge that's that's your right
to do I try to never have that except
one page full of just one person's name
I know you of course you do and the the
only reason I can't even say his name
is because I believe this person has
committed crimes against humanity quite
like seriously oh yes you know what yes
right currently yeah okay so this person
was so awful to me and to Erica times
are way worse to me in college awful to
a girl that I dated that Eric later
dated for a reason he will never tell me
well there's a reason why we can't
reveal her here - yeah but either way he
was very terrible to her and in you know
things that that are that are honestly
like very very serious and bad and so I
hated him then he then used his power
because at a certain point he had an
amount of power in in ways that are
might be illegal against me per se
against this girl against people we knew
and so I just like this was the one
person I was like I'm gonna have a
grudge against this person and then we
move out to LA and lo and behold so does
that person and they try to first they
try to succeed in the same comedy
theater that we do and I never encounter
him during this time
but he is absolutely there at the same
time but he is so hateable
that he gets himself bandwidth in his
first like six months so he was been
interned there and they completely
banned him it's just I think crimes
against humanity again and then you know
I was like good because I didn't want to
run into this guy I don't want to ever
have to act on the fact that I have
somebody on my enemy list and then years
pass and I get into YouTube work I start
working in YouTube and I start working
for a youtuber who's a comedy youtuber
specifically he knew me from doing
comedy back in Florida and you know
somebody else who did comedy back in
Florida hits him up and it's like hey I
would love to work for you and weirdly
cuz this guy is oblivious mentions I
know Phillip works for you I'm sure that
you know he'd love to work with me too
which like oh man could not be more
wrong so the guy calls me and this is
the one time in my life I get he was
like I just need you know you listed you
as a reference why would he do that why
would he think he must be so delusional
if you think said he would be a good
reference for us so what do you think
should we hire him I said yeah you can
totally hire him and I will quit the
moment and so he did not hire him and
then I then I started working doing new
rock stars and there was a time when new
rock stars look like it was all gonna
fall apart this is at that time when the
whole company was going under and it
wasn't even really new rock stars yet
I'm sorry I was gonna lose my job
so I picked up another job running a
YouTube channel for a much bigger
company and I was the the creative
director which like there it was a very
high level position at this this large
company but the only reason I'm calling
out there was high level is that there
were a lot of people below me it was if
there's a reason this company failed
they blew way too much money every video
that I made had a budget of $20,000
which was stupid yeah so it was real
stupid and they put me in charge so you
know the good show but that meant that
on one day I'm sitting at my desk and I
kind of just like look out the doorway
and I see the guy just walking right by
and then he does the backwards walk and
he leans in and he's like hey you you
work here
and then he kind of like sees my my sign
on the door and stuff and he's like oh
you're uh in charge of this whole thing
now I was like yeah oh I said he's like
would be great to catch up or something
I was like huh hmm I just got hired out
PA on I think one of your shoots and I
was like really interesting he's like
all right well I'll see you on set and
he walked away and I just watched him
walk away I get up and I go to the
producer who is I'm like the guy who
works for me I'm like that guy right
there you hired him as a PA and he's
like oh I think the coordinator somebody
I don't know epa's and I was like he's
gone he's not on the shoot and he was
like alright I'll make it happen the one
time in my life I've ever pulled a move
like that get one I was like yeah
exactly and I felt like and it's weirdly
I'm I'm so not that type that I still
feel guilty even telling this story but
you are one of the few people who knows
how tell yeah yeah god you you were even
diplomatic you should've like put him on
blast this guy's yeah I didn't I didn't
even say why I was just like I just I
don't feel comfortable working with that
guy
yeah alright so I don't want on one side
and so they went and like he wasn't his
name was taking off the call sheet I
think they gave him a fake address to
show up to in the middle of the ocean
and then I never talked to him again but
then I mean maybe we're asking for this
whatever the guy was so obsessed with
trying to work in YouTube
he made his own channel and I don't want
to even send anyone to it I don't want
to talk about it too much because it is
one of the channels that is responsible
for putting out conspiracy theories on
the internet about people being secret
pedophiles or trying to get people to
not just feel rage at at political
figures whatnot but also like try to
like tear their lives apart and just the
disgusting lies all the worst stuff that
ever happens near any election season
this is one of the sources is this guy's
channel so sort of saying we're it's
like recent crimes against humanity so
this is the one person on my entire list
that I ever and at some point I'll find
it I'll find I'll finally end up
forgiving him or something don't you
ever the one person that I've ever felt
like I've specifically actively bullied
and I did it as an adult yeah this
sounds less like bullying and more like
righteous
justice and balance and scale tipping
like because this man I wish we could go
into the details but we we don't want
identify this person we don't want to
give them any odds we'd open ourselves
up also to legal issues right so if you
give us names this is this person we're
not gonna acknowledge it and just
because we don't we don't want him to
get any more views as a result of us
yeah this guy's he's is a real-life bad
guy you know what he is he is like Gary
and Pokemon or blue right so like any
time you think you have moved on in your
life this [ __ ] shows back up and
he's got a battle um and you gotta take
him down it's like guess I'm I'm done
with the Elite Four
wait Gary's back how does this guy keep
coming back and it just gets worse and
worse and he's gone on his own weird
evolved career track that just seems
like the bizarro opposite of what you
think the right thing is but it's just
like it's like God put him on this earth
to be your your bizarro and that's
that's he's your bizarro yeah fine he's
my bizarro and we're anti each other
forever if you really want to know who
it is
the clue I'll give you is seed Riggs
oh no that's obvious right Chandler are
all right this guy just oh man the
trouble he's caused I'm kidding I like
Jace whoa hold on a sec it Kelly is that
an earthquake are you feeling that yeah
that's an earthquake 2020s happening
again so we should probably wrap this up
we should that is our show reminder that
you can join our official discourse by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars and you get an audio
version of the show by subscribing a new
rock stars big question wherever you get
your podcast thanks to everyone who
submitted questions people who tweeted
at us course our discord friends who
sent us some really really great
questions this week you can also mail us
your questions at our p o-- box and
tweet us your questions using the
hashtag big question follow me at a vos
follow Phillip at Phillip Malina and
follow new rock stars on socials and
subscribe here on YouTube to get too
much information about all the
step you care about see you next week
let's get under our desks right yeah
[Music]